with almost 15 million subscribers on
her YouTube channel and she's conquered
basically every aspect of media at this
point Canada's own little saying made a
big announcement when she was a guest on
Jimmy Fallon last night she's getting
her own NBC late-night talk show that
will follow Jimmy and Seth Meyers
that's called yes it has a name
yes it's called a little late with Lilly
Singh fallish probably September Wow and
I'm so excited because I truly get to
create a show from scratch you know I
get to make it inclusive I get to create
its comedy segments and interview people
and really create something that I
believe in and I'm so honored and
humbled sure and what's the show gonna
be like is it channel but just you know
now I have more than three staff members
gonna be me then Seth Meyers and then
you yeah we're in the NBC a huge shout
out to all the women who have been
before me and are currently in the space
because I couldn't have done it without
them paving the path yeah Canadian woman
also because you're in the NBC
late-night family everyone please
welcome the host of Late Night with Seth
Meyers
[Applause]
[Applause]
I want to take a photo now we're in the
embassy cameras to a cheesy family photo
there we go
that's how I take all my photos so lots
of slabs are sending their well wishes
to Lily
now Lily helped out Dwayne Johnson with
his introduction to YouTube with his
first video he tweeted she's come a long
way
proud of you sis and Nick Jonas added
yes so awesome Congrats in Carson Daly
the guy Lily will be replacing in the
late-night line event for 17 years and
nothing but good things to say Lily I'm
so genuinely excited and happy for you
in quite frankly NBC they gave me a shot
which I'm forever grateful for now you
have more than earned this moment go
kick some late-night dudes butts and no
I'm rooting for you
so yeah it's cool like I mean Zoe said
Zoe says always said Lily is funny but
not late-night show funny material no
offense I think it'll be interesting
though because she is building her show
from scratch and the idea you know for
sure is to bring her fan base over to
watch this show at that digital firm
that digital fan base so she'll be
obviously I think they'll probably
tailor things to the format and the time
limit that they've got on the show but
if you are a fan of Lily's saying in her
comedy I'm sure it's gonna be like
releasing all the way through and I
think true with talk shows I think it's
absolutely impossible to predict what's
gonna work and what doesn't you seen
over the last you know 10 years some
people get a talk show everything oh
that's perfect but then something just
doesn't gel and then some unexpected
people like oh this totally works I
never would have thought so I find it
completely hard to predict if someone's
gonna work with Fallon who now like
arguably is the king of late-night him
and Colbert probably his first few
episodes if you go back and watch those
you can see where they're kind of
learning gonna work on playing and
exactly exactly yeah someone's this
happy for Lily she deserves to come up
to TV
you